this young corny and cliche but is
always sunshine after the rain you're
gonna say rain don't live that long
you got to know that be aware that life
is a game life is a chess match you got
to go into a confidence you can't be
timid all the time anything you put in
your subconscious mind it becomes a
reality so I tell myself constantly this
is easy this is easy no matter what the
task is he's the CEO and the founder of
a supplements company
he's a former professional boxer he's
the author of the overtraining series of
ebook he is Mike Rasheed and here's my
take on his top ten rules of success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys as
you're watching the videos if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well also as you are
writing something down it's much more
likely to stick in your head to enjoy
different types of people in this world
and one thing that we'll all want to
deal with is like difficulties in our
tasks trying to become successful as
good as things get you would have a same
amount of bad that's going to try to
impede your progress whether it be
people whether it be a IRS whether it be
whatever something will rear its ugly
head and try to block you now a lot of
people can't handle this when you have a
vision and something or someone throws a
curveball
it hurts things right it's like your
baby and now I can't put my baby out
there like I want to do it so it really
throws people off because any negatives
they may get the president want to stop
and I wanted to go back to the amount of
body that's fine is not for everybody to
push through but for those who can
please do like you said the difference
between those who really succeed well
done are the ones who when they're faced
with whatever it is difficulties are
they like imma keep pushing through I'm
gonna keep which to because this sound
corny and cliche but it's always
sunshine after the rain you're gonna
stand rain don't live that long
you got to know that be aware that
that's what you can take with you
anything in life but in business you
cannot stop because things and I want to
write at the time because it's going to
happen I deal with which are due to
begin at some point so anyway I always
made sure I was the best in the best
shape when people were in the gym they
saw a serious I was with my clients they
also saw how hard I was training on my
own so it was not hard for me to get
clients now when I decided to leave the
gym and go independent this was already
a goal of mine I read out I've written
out all of my goals writing goals are
very important it is very important I
wrote my goals out and I think it was
like ten of them and then a year later
maybe two years later I went back to
that book and I sweating everything I've
written out I hate it without even
thinking about it it's something
powerful about writing your goals
Tidus training
I work my ass off I had the worst hours
starting at 5:00 in the morning and I
closed the gym it's funny I'm I'm
thinking about this now because the end
of my training career I decided my work
and I was a successful trying anything
but anyway I would break in the middle
day but I'm working towards all the
hours trying to generate business so
when I did I established a very solid
clientele base a core group of people a
lot of them and I was very very very
dedicated to them you know I would get
you know you know all you need is one
certification I got three you know I
mean always trying to better myself it's
reading struggling and I'll always try
to be the example as well making sure
I'll never have somebody coming my gym
that it's in better shape to me that was
my mind-state when I expand this is
anything in my life I always have a lot
when you see me you see a lot of people
I always have a lot of responsibility
and I've always had a lot of
responsibility I'm not comfortable
without a lot of responsibility some
people is fresh and thin but I just grow
more there's more me now you know I mean
so I'm trying to take on more things
tackle more thing I'm strong enough to
do it you know and every sense of the
word and that's really I didn't know it
is with you know and my mentality is
like I have a I don't loose mentality
and that's what any that's not just like
say a sporting event or whatever that's
just life right
because life is non-stop test you know I
mean and we're always being put to a
test there's always challenges obstacles
etc and I literally don't accept any of
that as a impediment as a negative it's
like good this is going to make me
stronger I want to learn something from
this you don't have no life especially
when you're a successful personal
trainer you know it's hard to take a
vacation because you take a break you
don't train anybody for that week that's
a week further that you're going to get
paid is this a you know any any trainers
out there yeah I know what I'm talking
about but it is
a good job it is very rewarding you do
learn a lot of leadership skills and if
you got to take a serious toll but it
was very nerve-racking very scary to
step out and try to do things on my own
but you know what it was the best
business decision that I ever made and
I'm glad I did it you know
I'm a risk taker you got to be willing
to take those risks you got to bet it
all on yourself and believe in yourself
and ABI and listen up you you like when
you take that risk when you step out
there and step away from that safe nine
to five you have to and I didn't rely on
nobody and family friends nothing nobody
I just had me you have to survive you
have to make it you in deep water
you either drown or you swim it's up to
you always look at that for a while man
like I've always been a very like like I
always had a lot of for spot and
everything I do although you successful
or whatever I did so I would like the
adventure is kind of like out of trick
well I was never scared to take risk
right
so I appeared when I was taking the
wrong kind of risk you know and my
fighting style led to that I would let's
just kind of hang on the wrong dudes
wrong people it just marks just being
stupid man that like I see aliens and
young stupid big on saying I was greatly
in your tub raised in a really good
family my father's a very intelligent
person yeah like I refer to his quotes
and wisdom all the time yeah so I was
really in here aligning with my laps and
body got so appointment yeah I guess the
people was around me I had a bunch of
parasites and leeches around me and you
know I liked it for whatever we're
eating and I'm saying and all some
people are attracted to that comes yeah
yeah so but I'll you know I learned my
lesson and I corrected my ways I had to
go through a lot like like being
homeless types you know I mean while
almost losing my freedom and you know I
went through a lot and I kept my head up
I persevered
I didn't lay down to my problems I
handled him I faced it and came out is
so much better right I got so much to
give people now because I did that to a
lot of it makes sense now I'm very
saying because the way that you talk is
it's kind of Stern and straight to the
point
and so it's like ah guys kind of speaks
hopefully it's pretty been through here
you gotta you dug yourself alright grab
yourself by the bootstraps and we're
able to wrap here I got taking the deep
waters yes when I'm back I've had other
people in deep waters I swam out there
and brought them back right
numerous times so I've been to a lot
like right and I feel like that makes me
so strong I got to a point it was like a
crossroads where I was like lay down and
die and be a loser and my kids look at
me in disgust or do something with my
life
so I got this some of my life so I wrote
out a plan this is something that people
that you got a you got to do you got to
take theory it's a saying I don't know
who said but it from knowledge it says
people don't plan to fail they fail to
plan so basically everything is a
process right so if you are I want a
million dollars we can go get a million
dollars it is no different than making a
sandwich you longer you make a sandwich
what you do
get up you walk through the kitchen get
your bread out goes will process the
same thing with becoming successful and
whatever you want to do so or whatever
your goal is you figure out what that
process is you do your research people
and then you make a plan you write it
out competent people get a lot further
in life than people that are not
confident it is what it is because a
confident person will step out on his
own faith and and try to do things
outside of their norm you know a
confident person will take chances that
are non competent person won't you know
I'm not saying the arrogant I'm not
saying being [ __ ] none of that
because I don't like people like that
you know but being confident is nothing
wrong with that
you know I got a sports background
mostly I'll do two
you know I used to box I'm gonna go in
the ring
confidence to let this guy know that I'm
trying to knock your head off
you know I'm saying I want him to know
or think in his mind that I know for a
fact that I'm an octave head off
you know what I mean that little mint to
intimidation is going to go a long way
in that particular flight in that boxing
match you know and that's life life life
is a game
life is a chess match
you got to go into a confidence you
can't be timid all the time you know I'm
not saying just leap out of the frying
pan into the fire in every situation you
got to be smart and calculative however
if you don't have that confidence you
know if some Bulls up there they tear
you apart is dog-eat-dog sometime you
know and people just like animals humans
can smell fear they can see a timid
person a lot of people don't want to go
into business with a timid person a lot
of people can't trust attended person a
lot of people don't want to attend a
person to have their back they don't
want to be a team with that person I
live I live pretty much five days a week
I look probably about my session
sometime they give me 30 minutes
sometimes 90 minutes so it varies and
also guys you know I've been listen I
was a young guy like I sort of I think I
started actually lifting weight when I
was 12 years old we had those concrete
weights with the plastic to cover it you
know the Sun kind of cracks the crack
plastic and every time you do a curl a
chunk of cement falls out of the weights
and balance one thing I can say about my
listing regiment is I am very consistent
I can't think of a time on my life that
I haven't
and as every group of friends I've ever
had I'm the ringleader when it comes to
training but everybody's trying to get
them around so I've been get the clever
I'm thinking about making the hardest
thing look easy so if you ever around me
when I train a lot of times I'm psyching
myself up I'm like this is easy it's
easy this is a warm-up give me more
weight I say that to myself and I
believe it you know anything you put in
your subconscious mind it becomes a
reality so I tell myself constantly this
is easy this is easy no matter what the
task is now you take that is given a gym
okay this is a direct parallel to life
to everyday situation whether it be work
school relationship space in a conflict
okay when you constantly put yourself
through a difficult task stay like a
really difficult workout in the gym when
it's when it's something positive for
you you constantly push yourself to that
you will be able to like outside the gym
handle any situation because you develop
that mental toughness it's way more than
physical and that's why I try to get it
across my training the way I train yeah
I want to be physically fit I want to be
strong when it be healthy I want to look
good but also I want to strong mine okay
I tell people all the time
train your mind it's hard to train your
body
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because JP asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it
down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know what
did you learn today from Mike that had
the biggest impact on you what message
really stuck with you that you're going
to immediately apply somehow to your
life or to your business leave it down
the comments below and I'm going to join
in the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout - Vishal Singh thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and making that fun
youtube tribute video I really really
really appreciate your support
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is let's love I'll see you
soon
personal training is a very very
rewarding job and more ways than one
you can make decent money as a personal
trainer but it's not about the money
it's about really changing these lives
like touching lives I had people I had a
woman who I hope I helped her lose a
hundred pounds she was like this
she was an obese morbidly obese and took
what I was doing with her she was a hot
fit chick there was an old guy I love
this guy he was in his 70s very very
sedentary lifestyle where Hinda wasn't
about to lifting weights we did a few
things for resistance training but you
know I do some boxing gloves on him and
he'll miss and it gave him life he loved
it so you find what these people want to
do you find something that works for
them something's going to keep them
healthy alive and vibrant and then you
run with that you know so it was very
rewarding in that sense but like I said
over produce whatever your goal is you
know I don't get working and Donald do
more because what you're doing is you're
making it so important you're not going
to be the guy when budgets need to be
pruned budget cuts are on the table your
name is not even want to be in the
conversation right now we say radios
learning and on be developing and
impeccable work capacity and ethic which
if you ever do become your own boss or
manager whatever you already have that
achievement unlocked already you know
nice oh that's so much dozen winnable so
over devote and I tell people it's about
being a winner you know my arms my
supplement company is called I'm so
alpha I didn't come up with that you
know I would put stuff out like pictures
and videos and stuff and like people
would just hashtag like that's so alpha
so now for we love that it's just a mind
state right so and when I say that like
people think all that super arrogant and
cocky is not there's nothing wrong with
being confident for one because when you
are legitimate when you really like
qualify yourself and whatever fill you
you're in you know and you handle
business you got the work to show for it
why not be confident you know some
people mistake that for arrogance or
cockiness I'm not about that you know
I'm about being confident
I can't help it you know um so you you
conduct yourself in a certain way so
it's a whole lifestyle that I push with
the type of training that I do you know
it goes into my everyday life I can't
help it you know that's why the
companies iron so alpha I hashtag and I
got shirts that say output is like I'm
really gonna do this you're on me
whatever it is anything like any kind of
challenge I'm like I want to do it I
want to do oh that's hard yeah I think
okay let me do it I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna do it harder and I'm gonna you
know add more weight and I'm gonna do it
you know I'm saying so you know it just
mentioned Lea sets you up for life to be
a winner I'm all about being a winner
and I'm not talking about one stage
that's not really winning is it you know
it's not a competition you're getting
judged by people who don't live you
understand so winning in life winning in
life is like like winning in life is
like you know you're your kid is
struggling in the subject you figure out
a way to get them up to speed you know
you've got an argument with your
girlfriend or your boyfriend you're not
going to let this person walk away
unhappy like y'all going to figure it
out yummy that's winning in life you
don't saying it's a conflict at work you
handle it you step up and handle it
you're winning at life if you don't I
mean and that's what it's all about
being a winner at life at everything